candace is with us in indianapolis hi
candace welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hey what's up how are you
better than i deserve me too
um i'm calming today because i currently
rent a condo and my
landlord who owns the unit reached out
to me and would like to sell
the condo i am in a leaf
and so it was a two year lease and i
have one year left
and he would like to sell it but would
like me to
move out and so i'm trying to figure out
what's an appropriate amount to ask for
almost like a cash for keys agreement
that in which case he would pay me to
vacate early
because he is requesting that i
terminate the lease
um and so i'm just a little not sure
what i should ask for or if i should
just say no
and just stay in the condo for another
year until my lease expires
[Music]
well if i were in your shoes or if the
rolls were reversed
um and you were in his shoes you would
want to work something out
i got a feeling it could get really
awkward if you just hang out there for a
year
yes i feel like it would be awkward yeah
so
i mean let's do something i don't know
why he's asking you to terminate the
lease he's the one asking
i mean you would have to agree to the
least termination
obviously and but i don't know why he he
is trying to posture to where you
terminate the lease he can
terminate the lease but he can only do
it with compensation that you've agreed
to so i mean either way we're
we're adjusting we haven't we have a
written agreement we're going to adjust
that written agreement
to you leaving okay now does he want you
out and he's going to renovate before he
sells or could you stay until it's sold
so he offered well he initially offered
me
two thousand dollars to stay until it
sold
but i wouldn't receive those funds until
the condo transaction
closed um he doesn't want to renovate it
he actually offered it to me
but i just can't it just needs a lot of
work yeah and it has very high
delays okay so how much is your rent how
much is your rent
900 a month okay
all right that doesn't sound
unfair did it feel unfair to you
um it felt unfair just that i would have
to obviously agree to showings
and basically i wouldn't i would be
living in limbo
not knowing when the condo might sell
and then he would give me
14 days he said to relocate and so
um okay well let's just negotiate let's
negotiate a little bit okay
you said it's 900 rent okay
i'll stay at six hundred dollar rent and
two thousand dollars when i leave
the difference in the 300 is me keeping
the place clean and ready to sell
and i i can't be gone in 14 days i'll
need 30 days notice
okay yeah that sounds fair because i
want to be fair he has been a good
landlord
and well there's not a there's not
anything wrong with any number here that
makes the number fair or unfair
unless it just got grotesque you know
and and then nobody's going to do it but
anything you two agree to
is fair because you two agreed to it
both of you did
okay and would you recommend that i
received the money after this
trip after the condo closed it's
probably the only way you're gonna get
it because he's probably get it's
probably the only place he's got any
money
okay yeah but i mean the
rent the rent reduction i've done this
as a landlord myself
where i offer a rent reduction and you
keep it clean and show ready
and very accessible you're not hard to
get along with for the realtor coming in
and basically you're being compensated
for all that 300 bucks a month in your
case and with my example
and then you have to get you have to
give 30 days notice and uh
and upon closing i get 2 000 and you put
all of that of course in writing
okay that sounds like a good plan
yeah and then you're out you're out of
his way he gets everything he wants you
get everything you want and
if it takes a little while to sell you
got a good deal
that's a really good plan dave just gave
you and i would i would lead with an in
person i know you need to get it in
writing but i would
dave i just believe in a phone call you
know where people can hear your emotions
and humility and say hey
thank you for the offer i need to spend
some time on it i really want this to
work out i want to help you do this
yeah i'm going to send you a couple
things couple thoughts that just little
extra touch
takes away the the defensiveness or the
thing i worry about with emails these
days
you know people try to do things
electronically they read in emotion
sometimes that aren't there so i think
dave's plan is brilliant i would just
add that little personal touch
and i think it'll go well yeah you can't
read anything and it's
uh and the problem is this uh yeah yes
call him and and talk about it and then
follow up with an email yes
absolutely really good suggestion and uh
people and i guess it includes even me i
was gonna i was gonna make it
generational but it's
not uh texting and uh
emails are so common that everybody does
that
and like a friend of mine was talking to
his son who's in his 30s who just turned
down a
uh had two great job offers on the table
and he turned down one of them
and he said you need to call them and
tell them thank you yes
for the offer because you may end up
working for them in 10 years
and you need to have a you need to make
a connection there because very
you know very high-end job you know
several hundred thousand dollars a year
type thing and you need to maintain that
relationship you don't text them and go
i'm going with the other guy
you know which you know because i but
somehow we've lost that uh training
yes my grandmother would say we lost the
training when we quit
writing handwriting letters for snail
mail and putting a stamp on them
true story i was just getting ready to
say back in the day you know we would
write letters and we'd send them to
people
and if we got one in the mail we would
open it up and what would we do we'd
open up we'd read it we'd read all the
things we'd go great then we'd probably
go get ourselves a t
or maybe we'd return the letter two
three days later nobody returned it
right away
but the tyranny of the urgent our
culture this is a this is a cultural
issue this is a worldwide thing
text email fast fast fast go go go go go
it's been three minutes and you
unanswered me
right and by the way i just read some
data i just read some data for people
that are working from home
dave you're gonna love this because
we're all about working in a building
and here's some more
stuff to put in your in your in your
bank here you ready for this
50 of people that are working from home
they've been working from home during
the pandemic would rather clean their
toilets than answer more emails
and chats that are all work related
because here's the deal they're over
compensating people over compensating
because they're not in the office where
they can walk to somebody's desk and go
hey
got an idea what do you think about this
what may take five minutes turns into 10
15 emails and maybe 45 minutes of your
day
people would rather clean their toilets
than answer more email
that's new data i'm just telling you so
what's wrong with the human touch
we've gotten away from talking to people
we're zoomed out baby
just because everybody else is doing it
to your example of the young man turning
on a high-end job
just because everybody else will say no
we're never sure we're not trained in it
anymore no we're not trying i i wasn't
trained in letter writing
i mean i actually did i actually did
learn cursive writing uh
which was still a thing back then i did
too it was horrible but i did it oh it's
horrendous uh made my grandmother cringe
because she taught second grade and
talked cursive for her
but her penmanship was beautiful it was
absolutely fabulous yeah
yeah that was a craft back then it was
you know it's a lost art and it's it's a
shame in that in
a very real thing um yeah people don't
send love letters anymore
yeah it's gone the romance of it's gone
it's just it's a thing so yeah there's
all of that goes with it so that's
really good suggestion for candace
and you know the other thing is if
you're gonna have a difficult
conversation those of you out there
talking about
money stuff and you've got a landlord
dispute or you've got a uh
you know a business a dispute with a
business firing off
uh stuff on twitter is you know pick up
the phone yeah and call them yeah
yeah send blazing hate mail email
anonymous bullcrap as if that's going to
fix anything
but this is this is the lack of training
in how to
get people to move to your side of an
equation and it requires an
actual conversation with a human that's
right technology is wonderful
technology's not evil in and of itself
but when it replaces the human
connection
i mean connection sitting across from
somebody and seeing oh they look a
little tense what can i do to drop that
down
or they react to me and i go maybe i'm
coming on a little strong i see how
they're reacting
folks this is god-given instinct to be
able to connect and communicate
we are relational human beings put the
phone down
get away from the keyboard make a
connection for crying out loud
calluses on our thumbs yes